Law 4: Equipment.
Typical soccer equipment consists of shorts, jersey, shin guards,...
...long socks that go over the shin guards and soccer cleats.
In official games, the referee controls time and may add extra time for injuries,...
...subs or anything else that cause the game to pause.
The ball is out of play when the ball has completely left the field.
If the ball is touching the touchline in the air or on the ground,...
...it is still considered in play.
The referee and goalpost are fixtures of the field...
...and play resumes when it hits any part of the fixtures.
Fouls.
A foul is when a player breaks a rule like using hands or pushing, tripping, pulling, etc.
If the referee deems it dangerous, he may call it a foul.
There are minor and major fouls.
The referee decides and may give a yellow card or red card...
...if he she believes it merits a warning for ejection of the game.
A free kick is awarded to the other team for a foul or handball.
Throw-in.
When the ball leaves the field over the sideline,...
...a throw-in is awarded to the team that did not touch the ball last.
Both feet need to touch the ground and the throw needs to be executed with both hands on the ball.